Li's going to start this hour off in
Idaho hi Lee how are you hi Dave how are
you I'm good good how can I help
well we've been working your Total Money
Makeover plan since last March the last
year we paid off around eleven thousand
dollars in debt but recently what
happened was we had a house that we rent
out now and we bought another home
so we're renting this other home and we
live in a different residence and I
received the escrow statement from the
bank which the payments going up $200 a
month because we don't qualify for the
tax exemption any longer which is fine
so that got me to thinking I'm going to
have to redo the budget and all this
good stuff my question is I recently
discovered that my husband has opened up
another credit card and he has put three
thousand dollars of charges on this card
and I just found out about it when
sporting goods you name it it's really
just hobby stuff he did Big D Bear and
things like that so it wouldn't be
anything for a package to arrive here
and there he'd buy and sell things all
the time
when we started the Total Money Makeover
we we sold a lot of extra things that we
had we had a garage sale we did all that
stuff he came clean about the credit
card finally while I opened the mail
because the lure was hey I applied for
this credit cards I could get a hundred
dollar gift card to REI which I thought
was weird I mean why would you apply for
a credit card
all for a hundred dollar gift card
didn't make any sense
I'll come to find out he'd had a PayPal
account paid all credit card I guess
with a 0% interest the interest was
about to expire on it he wouldn't be
able to make the payments without me
knowing so he was his intention was to
transfer the debt to this other card
and try to hide it then we get a minimal
allowance each week you know how they
react when you confronted him with the
fact they've been lying first he was
angry he was out of town I said I don't
receive him he was angry angry why would
he be angry because I opened the mail
initially so it's none of my business
allowed to open your own mail it was his
mail well you're married right
okay so he was really ready he was angry
and then he called back and apologized
and said I know it's wrong I'm glad it
came out I need help with this I don't
know why I did it I feel like when we
first started that he said he felt like
when we first started the plan that he'd
have no fun money he wasn't ready I mean
he wasn't ready to fully commit mm-hmm
he he told me that he's going to
counseling you're going to get
counseling he's made an appointment to
understand his to try to deal with those
issues of control or anger or whatever
sparked him to feel like he like he
wasn't having any control or any say I
do all the finances so we didn't
allowance and why why did he not get
involved in the finances when you start
the dough money makeover he did we I do
all the finances what's that mean just
that I do the budget we look at it you
know I guess we haven't been not
diligent about sticking to the budget
and I admit that as well
and but now we learn about him having a
say in the budget say that again and
haven't been very diligent about him
actually having a say in the budget oh
no he has a say in it I don't think he
didn't not you know he's kind of like
well if this is how we're going to do it
that's fine not so sure what's your
question as I trust you my question is I
we set aside $3,100 for kind of a rainy
day for this other home that we own in
the event that a tenant vacates and we
need to cover the payment for a couple
months that money's there dua and tax
seasons coming up and I know we'll have
to pay some taxes which is fine do I
take that money and and pay off this
this chunk of debt or do I save that
money in case the end in a cave I'm not
sure what to do I know that money
charging for me
what's that house worth more than we are
less than we owe 180 and I would love to
sell it yeah but I'm gonna have to wait
another year or two
yeah I'd really like to hear you all
change your pronouns from I - we well
you guys were actually working together
um it sounds like you do everything and
he just kind of was going along it
really does sound like you're dominating
this entire deal right and that he's not
having a say and he wasn't for some
reason man enough to say hey I I'm not
okay with this mm-hmm that he wasn't
okay with it in the beginning but I mean
he didn't follow through to the point
that he and that he turned now he's lied
and now you've got a break and Trust in
your marriage because once someone's
willing to hide something then you
wonder what else they're hiding right
and we've had that conversation yeah
it's more than a conversation um
the so I'm I probably would not leave
you completely broke and pay this debt
off I would put the dead in the dead
snowball if you're paying off other
debts and obviously cut up the card and
you all have got to revise your marriage
and your budgeting process okay and you
know really he has got to do some things
to rebuild trust and you got to do some
things to make sure that he is you know
having his say because for some reason
he's having trouble doing that and you
know him it's really really time that
y'all
rests on these issues in your
relationship that's a whole lot bigger
deal than the three thousand bucks it
could have been thirty thousand you know
we call this in our world we call this
financial infidelity when one spouse
lies to the other one about money or and
or hides debt because it's still it's
broken trust and it's hiding and it's
deception and it's lying and so it still
breaks the same it still touches the
same place in your heart that sexual
infidelity touches and for some people
it's actually worse which I can't grasp
that one but either way it's broken
trust and it it affects the quality of
the relationship and where we go from
here so yeah you guys have really got to
put the budgeting system and the way you
have the conversation around the budget
or you're both involved and we are
looking at this house we are making
these decisions about our money we are
on fire to get out of debt we want to
save money for emergencies and you know
and he needs to not just be tagging
along like you're his mother that that's
just broken here and that's a big deal
that's a hundred thousand dollar deal
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you